special counsel Robert Muller has gotten
president Trump's longtime personal
lawyer Michael Cohen to plead guilty to
lying to Congress so now we are all
expected to believe the guy who has
admitted that he's a liar we will
examine the central problem of Muller's
investigation thus far then CNN
celebrates the possibility of
impeachment Barack Obama reminds us how
awful he is and the ladies of the view
try to forget him
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
every day another one dropping in the
Muller investigation they're turning it
on Trump they're going for impeachment
there's a big big problem in this
investigation and we I'm sorry hold on
we before we can get to the Bob Muller
investigation we have breaking news
coming in this yes it has been confirmed
a creepy porn lawyer Michael avenatti is
still a dirtbag that is that is now
being confirmed around that's on the
wires it's being confirmed all around
Michael avenatti of dirtbag not exactly
a Man Bites Dog sort of story but this
is this is just delightful it turns out
that Michael avenatti has been
improperly using funds that were donated
to stormy Daniels has been doing things
that she didn't want him to do on her
behalf pretending to be her here is
stormy Daniels's statement that you gave
to The Daily Beast yesterday quote
Michael has been a great advocate in
many ways I'm tremendously grateful to
him for aggressively representing me and
my fight to regain my voice we'll get to
that in a second but in other ways
Michael has not treated me with the
respect and deference an attorney should
show to a client he has spoken on my
behalf without my approval he filed a
defamation case against Donald Trump
against my wishes he repeatedly refused
to tell me how my Legal Defense Fund was
being spent now he has launched a new
crowdfunding campaign using my face and
name without my permission and
attributing words to me that I never
wrote or said first before we get to any
of this
when did stormy Daniels lose her voice
all I've noticed is stormy Daniels
talking talking about president Trump's
genitals giving interviews even after
she took money in exchange for not
describing the sexual encounter she's
going on news show she's going on comedy
shows I don't I never saw stormy Daniels
losing her voice but it's just one of
those stupid slogans that that lefties
say that don't really mean anything the
real meat of this here pun unintended is
that Michael has not treated me with the
respect and deference an attorney should
show to a client gee do you think is
that is that really so what is he being
accused of he's being accused of taking
the money that was donate
to her just taking it without her
consent not telling her where the money
was being spent and using it for his own
purposes now he is saying that he's
given you know she's used some of the
money for security and he's taken the
rest for his legal fees but now he
started a new crowdfunding campaign in
her name that she has nothing to do with
this by the way is why very often it's
not a good reason or it's not a good
idea to donate to crowdfunding campaigns
you have no idea who's running them it
might be on behalf of somebody but you
don't know where that money is going you
don't know how it's gonna be spent we're
we're so tempted because of our
compassion to just throw money at
anything but sometimes it ends up going
to guys like Michael avenatti and but
this other one he filed a defamation
case against Trump against my wishes
Michael avenatti said when he filed that
defamation suit that he was doing it on
her behalf he's representing her if he
is doing that now against her wishes
that's a serious issue I mean that could
carry legal consequences it could carry
consequences for his career so that
that's not good all of this so what's
the big takeaway he's almost certainly
going to be the 2020 Democrat nominee
for president he's all but locked it up
at this point he's abused women
he has improperly stolen charitable
donations this I think makes him an
honorary Clinton this is the definition
of being a Clinton he has already locked
it up Kamala Harris can go home Cory
Booker Liz Warren it's just there it's
over Michael avenatti is now a Democrat
presidential candidate par excellence
he's almost certainly violated the law
that that's it that's it he's got it
locked up congratulations nominee
Michael avenatti we look forward to a
full and robust general election
campaign in 2020 against Donald Trump
gonna be a lot of fun back to the major
news story not the not the news that
we've all known since Michael avenatti
first crawled out of whatever gutter
he's living in and got into another
gutter called CNN and showed his face on
TV the real story today is that Michael
Cohen the longtime personal attorney for
Donald Trump has pled guilty to lying to
Congress now this is a deal that was
reached with robert muller with the
special counsel
and it's it's another one of these plea
deals so what is it about what he what
he apparently allegedly lied about to
Congress is when a a deal in Moscow for
a Trump building was nixed when they got
rid of the deal what Michael Cohen was
saying to Congress is that the Trump
Organization was looking at building a
tower in Moscow they were going to do it
in 2015 and then by January 2016
by the time of the Iowa caucuses they
nixed the deal and there was no more of
that what Bob Muller has now gotten
Michael Cohen to plead guilty to lying
about is that they were still discussing
that Moscow deal even after the Iowa
caucuses into 2016 into the campaign so
here is Michael Cohen the guy the
personal lawyer who and the lawyer for
the Trump Organization who is coming out
and saying I lied Trump was trying to do
a deal in Moscow during the campaign he
is totally turning on Trump here and for
that to figure out some of this reaction
we can turn now to president Trump's
last interaction with Michael Cohen
correct and I'm the biggest mmm he's got
a lower voice and I remember seeing it
though at those White House conferences
but is what it sounds like it does sound
like these mob dealings did build in the
building they got to talk to the
enforces in Moscow you got Bob Mallory's
forcing these guys to start lying to
start telling narratives okay right
whatever
what didn't Muller actually file in this
filing he said quote in truth and in
fact and as Cohen well knew Cohen's
representations about the Moscow project
he made two House and Senate
intelligence committees were false and
misleading Cohen made the false
statements to give the false impression
that the Moscow project ended before the
Iowa caucus in the very first primary in
hopes of limiting the ongoing Russia
investigations so that's that's the
false statement the false statement is
maybe the Moscow talks in some form or
another went on longer than January 2016
maybe we Trump
stopped talking about it in January 2016
but people in the Trump Organization
we're still pursuing it maybe there was
an email that went out to some developer
in Russia maybe who knows who knows my
question is who cares who cares if it
ended in 2008 2016 or February or March
where is the law that says that a
presidential candidate can't continue to
own a business and he can't continue to
build his international real estate
empire overseas while he's running for
president he's not even the president
yet he's just running you know during or
after the Iowa caucuses president Trump
takes this same approach here is Trump
responding to the latest Muller plea
deal a position to possibly do a deal to
build a building of some kind in Moscow
I decided not to do it the primary
reason that could have been other
reasons but the primary reason it was
very simple I was focused on running for
president there would be nothing wrong
if I did do it so two statements in
there two things to look at he says I
dropped the deal in January so the rest
of us think why would he drop that deal
it's it could be a lucrative deal for
the Trump Organization why ended because
he was focused on running for president
fair enough let me tell you if you've
ever been on a campaign even a
congressional campaign or a local
campaign they are exhausting when you're
running for president you don't sleep
for 18 months so fair enough they don't
they're not gonna pursue this they'll do
it at a later time okay but then he
gives it an alternate theory which is
let's say he did do it let's say that he
was building this trying to build this
building in Moscow afterward so what
where is the law who cares now we we
have this intuition that it's against
the law we have this intuition that it's
wrong what if what if John McCain were
building a building in Moscow and what
if Barack Obama did what if what if
Hillary did it what it okay fine this is
what happens when you have a businessman
as president we don't we haven't had
businessmen as president in I don't I
don't know the last time we had a
businessman as President Truman maybe
was true true as a haberdasher or
something like that when was the last
time we've just
had career politicians Barack Obama
never held a private-sector job in his
life basically george w bush what you
know he owned a baseball team but he was
a he was governor he was you know he was
a he was a politician came from a
political dynasty family Bill Clinton
only ever ran for office right after law
school ran for attorney general did that
track George Bush Senior he was an oil
man in his young days but then he was a
career politician after that you know
he'd already finished his business
dealings by the time he was running for
office before before that it goes on and
on Ronald Reagan was a movie star so on
and so forth Donald Trump is a
businessman not in the way some
everybody has business interests his
business is business
he has a TV show about all the business
he did he's worked in so many different
industries casinos real estate golf
courses vodka that didn't last long
steaks television he's worked in all of
these different industries and so his
business is business and when you got a
businessman businessmen have business
interests all around the world and
that's perfectly fine it's it's a nice
thing to have a businessman in
government government moves very slow
its inefficient it isn't terribly
connected to the real world when you get
someone in there from the private sector
things move a little faster like we've
seen in this administration okay why
does Mulder care what why does that get
what does this deal in Moscow have to do
with the Clinton campaign and hack to
emails and what does it have to do with
anything what does it have to do with
the Trump campaign you know if the ideas
that he was continuing to pursue this
building at the time okay so then we're
told that the Russians decided to help
Trump become president so that he
wouldn't return to the private sector
and build that building in Moscow is
that the implication what what is the
this is the trouble with this whole
Russian narrative is they're trying to
construct a coherent storyline out of
random disparate events that have no
connection to one another so then the
question is why is Michael Cohen going
along with all this Michael Cohen once
said something to the effect of he would
take a bullet for Donald Trump before
he'd rat and then the dirty rotten rat
is ratting so
what is his incentive president Trump
explains that to go back and look at the
paper that Michael Kohn wrote before he
testified in the house and/or Senate it
talked about his position what he's
trying to do because he's a weak person
and not a very smart person what he's
trying to do is end and it's very simple
he's got himself a big prison sentence
and he's trying to get a much lesser
prison sentence by making up the story
now here's the thing even if he was
right it doesn't matter because I was
allowed to do whatever I wanted to in
the campaign I was running my business a
lot of different things during the
campaign so very simply Michael Kohn is
lying and he's trying to get a reduced
sentence but things that have nothing to
do with so Michael Cohen pleads guilty
this is a count it faces up to five
years in prison and a fine of $250,000
don't forget though Michael Cohen has
already pled guilty to eight criminal
counts he's pled guilty to bank fraud
tax fraud campaign finance violations
eight different counts that he's pled
guilty to only one of them had any
connection to the Trump campaign and
that's when Cohan paid off stormy
Daniels all the other seven have nothing
to do with the Trump campaign they have
everything to do with the time long
before the campaign when Michael Cohen
had his own private business
interactions so what's the timeline here
it's that Bob Muller takes Trump's
personal lawyer squeezes him says we're
gonna throw you in jail forever if you
on all of these other counts that you
had before you were the lawyer during
the campaign unless you rat on Donald
Trump he's got all of this incentive to
turn on Trump and do whatever Muller
wants if he doesn't say what Muller
wants he could rot in prison and so
let's say that this is true though let's
say that right now Cohen is telling the
truth
he lied to Congress but now he's telling
the truth the problem is he has no
credibility to use a word that has been
much abused in the last couple months it
not only does Michael Cohen not have any
credibility none of these guys have any
credibility none of Muller's star
witnesses have a shred of credibility
this is the Muellers central problem
right now Muller's central problems he's
built this entire case on calling people
liars and having people plead guilty
whether they were or not to having to
made a false statement or to being a
liar that's fine
but then we have no reason to believe
these witnesses how many times have they
changed their story changed their tune
what are the indictments so far the
indictment so far against Trump campaign
members are George papadopolis would
they get him on they got him on pleading
guilty to making false statements he was
in prison for 14 days so I guess the
statements were in that bad he was only
there for two weeks
Paul Manafort now there are more charges
against him why because he lied because
Muller was saying you're a liar you lied
even in your plea agreement with us you
are a liar
Rick Gates who is Paul manna forts
former deputy who you know had worked
with manna Ford on lobbying campaigns
pled guilty to making one false
statements charge Michael Flynn same
thing former national security adviser
pled guilty to false statements Alex
vanderzwaan
who's a dutch lawyer who was working
with rick gates pled guilty to making
false statements regarding his contact
with rick gates and now we have Michael
Cohen who's pled guilty to making false
statements to Congress all of the I'm
not saying that Muller central problem
is that he's dealing with Liars for us
you ters deal with liars all the time
the problem here is that all the crimes
that manoa that Muller rather has been
able to throw on these guys are the
crimes of lying so if that is all we
know about them if that is the whole
reason that they're in the position that
they're in why would we believe a single
word coming out of their mouth
especially now that we know that Paul
Manafort is allegedly a liar then he
enters into a play agreement and then he
lies about the plea agreement so now
he's got more charges on him why would
we believe any of these liars
if Muller had anything if Muller
actually had evidence that Trump
committed some crime with the Russians
or that some campaign member committed a
crime with the Russians he would ring
them up on those charges because then at
least you can say we've got you on this
if you flip but if all you can say is
we've got you on being a liar but now
you better tell the truth and I don't
care what you think the truth is you
say what I want the truth to be what
what truth what the truth would be if it
were convenient for me you've got
nothing that's just that is a less than
nothing so even I mean this is not a
good sign for the Mulder investigation
right now the Twitter or left wing
Twitter is so excited because Michael
Cohen pled guilty that's all it says on
Twitter by the way former Trump lawyer
Michael Cohen pleads guilty in court
guilty to what oh he's a liar okay okay
fine oh I wonder what he'll say now
maybe he'll talk about when he was
abducted by aliens and go to Planet
Zebulon seven there's no credibility at
all nevertheless CNN won't let this get
them down CNN's Jeffrey Toobin is so
excited he can he can just smell the
impeachment coming start with you what
do you make of President Trump
seemingly dangling a pardon for manna
for it is there anything legally dubious
about it is it obstruction of justice
well you have to remember that we are
now in the realm of possible impeach
impeachable offenses and that is much
more a political question than a legal
question is this something that would
motivate now a Democratic majority in
the House of Representatives to impeach
the president I mean my belief is that
the answer is no that Nancy Pelosi Jerry
Nadler they've told me and others they
don't want to deal with impeachment but
because they know that there will not be
67 votes in the Senate to remove the
president so they're just not going to
go on that fool's errand however that
shouldn't distract us from the fact that
this is egregiously inappropriate
behavior on the part of the president it
is all but an encouragement to tell to
Paul Manafort to stop cooperating to
don't get involved with Muller to take
your punishment I will take care of you
later
it's egregiously wrong but is it
something that will lead to impeachment
I don't think so is he right is it an
encouragement to these people not to say
whatever Muller wants them to say you're
damn right it is and it absolutely
should be because what Jeffrey Toobin
said at the beginning is absolutely
right
this has nothing to do with charging
someone with a crime this has everything
to do with politics and I'm beginning to
think that this whole Muller
investigation
is only about politics it has nothing to
do with crime it has nothing to do with
dredging up some crimes from 2013 some
tax issue to try to squeeze somebody to
sing a song some made-up fiction about
Donald Trump I'm beginning to think it's
all about politics I think it was about
politics when Peters struck first
started the investigation in the first
place and 15 days later called it an
insurance policy to stop Donald Trump I
think it was all about politics when the
FBI hired a paid Democrat operative to
come up with dirt on Donald Trump a guy
who had been paid by the DNC and Hillary
Clinton I think it's all about politics
now because there's no crime of
collusion they haven't accused these
guys of any crimes other than being
dirty rotten liars and they're trying to
use their lies to create the aura that
Donald Trump is a bad guy and he should
be impeached from from his office that's
what it's about how are they gonna get
Donald Trump
I don't think Bob Muller thinks he's
gonna get Donald Trump I think what
they're doing is just making him look
really really bad to either encourage
impeachment or to have him lose his
election in 2020 all about politics it's
always about politics with these guys
reminds me of the Obama administration
was that when everything was about
politics and he you have to watch this
he reminds you how terrible that
administration was he was giving a talk
at Rice University now Barack Obama is
lambasted our founders he's taking
credit for things that he has no
business taking credit for here is
Barack Obama on identity politics you
start getting politics that's based on
that person's not like me and it must be
their fault and you start getting the
politics based on a nationalism that's
not pride in country but hatred for
somebody on the other side of the border
and you start getting
[Applause]
the kind of politics that does not allow
for compromise politics does not allow
for compromise from Barack Obama who
said I won't work with Republicans I've
got a pan and a phone and I'll do
whatever I want
that's unbelievable he says that we hate
people on the other side of the border
we don't hate people on the other side
of the border we like them on the other
side of the border we want them to stay
on the other side of the border the
other side of the border is where they
belong because they're not American
citizens we don't we don't even hate
them when they get here we give them an
insane amount of welfare we treat them
very well we arrest them for committing
crimes and we still don't even deport
them and what an outrageous calumny to
say about his fellow citizens but that's
that's Barack Obama as all he does talks
about now now so he's he's able to
strictly lambaste President Trump even
during this very successful time in
office but he does this amazing thing
where he takes credit for all the good
stuff that Trump does and he voiced all
of the bad stuff that he did on to
Donald Trump here is Barack Obama
talking about taking credit trying to
take credit for the oil and natural gas
explosion I was extraordinarily proud of
the Paris Accords because look I know
you know you know I know we're in oil
country and we need American energy and
and by the way American energy
production you wouldn't always know it
but you know it went up every year I was
president and you know that whole
suddenly America is like the biggest oil
producer and the biggest get that was me
people I just want you to so two
thoughts here one Barack Obama the guy
who said individuals can't accomplish
anything and you didn't build that in
government does everything is now saying
I built that that was me direct quote
but to he's that isn't true that is just
flat-out wrong the the production of oil
by the federal government on federal
lands during Barack Barack Obama's
presidency was flat it didn't happen
there was no growth he's right there was
an oil and fracking boom that was all on
private land
in many ways that was in spite of his
administration which cut off oil
pipelines which constantly tried to hang
up the Keystone XL pipeline all of these
projects he was hugely anti oil
anti energy and now he's trying to take
credit for it which shows you something
a lot of times people on the Left wanna
paint him as an idealist though he's an
idealist he's too academic
he's too good for this world no he's a
hack despicable Chicago politician is
what he is who's willing to take credit
for things that he ostensibly opposes
when it suits his purposes because his
administration was an utter failure his
legacy has been erased and he's nobody
every Eve does these speaking things I
remember that he exists when I don't see
him on TV for more than three days I
forget he ever existed
his administration was that meaningless
and he goes on he can't give it up
here's here's the rest of the talk you
know what when I hear people say they
don't like identity politics they don't
like I think it's important to remember
that identity politics doesn't just
apply when it's Mike people or gay
people or women know the folks who
really originated identity politics with
folks who said you know three-fifths
clause and all that stuff that that was
identity politics that's still that's
still out there maybe maybe that was a
little too controversial for Houston but
yeah oh yeah that's that's what they
said Barack Obama constitutional lawyer
allegedly the framers of our
Constitution apparently they said
three-fifths clause and all that stuff
that's what they said not quite the
eloquence of Alexander Hamilton is it no
of course not Barack Obama though he's
using this little trick that lefties do
and it particularly lightly educated
lightly informed lefties which is
they'll just say a slogan so what he
didn't actually make a statement he said
identity politics or the people who who
say you know three-fifths clause and all
that stuff no no what did they say what
did they what is the three-fifths clause
he doesn't say that because it it
undercuts his entire point the
three-fifths compromise was a compromise
between slave states and free states
really but I suppose really the future
slave in free states
north in the south states with big slave
populations wanted to count slaves as
whole human beings now what Barack
Obama's trying to imply is that slaves
are they
we considered black people to only be
three-fifths of a human being that is
not what it was about at all in fact it
was just the opposite
the slaveholders wanted to count slaves
as full human beings because then their
states would be more populous and they
would have more representation in the
federal government the states with very
few slaves did not want to count the
slaves as whole people because the
slaves did not have any rights so if the
slaves don't have rights as people they
shouldn't be counted as the population
and the south shouldn't be able to
dominate the federal government they had
to come to this compromise to create the
country that ultimately elected Barack
Obama to our everlasting shame we
elected him but that was created by
those guys those awful terrible guys who
said you know like the three-fifths
clause and all that other stuff
what a hack what an absolute disgrace he
is to the country it's so sad he's
gotten worse since he's left office he
said I used to at least try to temper
his speech a little bit now it's just
all that Chicago trash it's really
really sad now what's really nice though
is that we have people in the White
House like Sarah Huckabee Sanders who
are fighting back against all of this
nonsense the left right now you know
they're trying to do the Obama trick
trying to give Obama credit for all the
good all the good Trump stuff and
pretend to know Obama never did any of
the sort of things that the Donald Trump
is doing Sarah Sanders puts an end to
that one particularly with regard to the
border crisis when does the White House
regret the that children were affected
by tear gas and that this situation
should play
these are an investigation underway to
prevent this from happening again
certainly the White House would never
want children to be in harm's way in any
capacity whatsoever however that is why
we are continuing to encourage people to
follow the law and go to ports of entry
law enforcement officials have used
appropriate non-lethal force to protect
themselves and prevent an illegal rush
across the border and let's also not
forget that this isn't the first time
that non-lethal force like this has been
used in fact tear gas was used on
average once a month during the Obama
administration for very similar
circumstances in fact they were actually
for far less circumstances because they
didn't have the same numbers in the mass
rush that we're seeing in this Caravan
take place once a month during the Obama
administration how do you like that have
you like them apples because now you're
seeing it being used because people are
throwing rocks at Border Patrol they're
trying to climb over and invade and run
through so they're using tear gas Barack
Obama used to your guests much much more
but you didn't first of all you didn't
hear a peep about it at the time because
the left doesn't really care they just
hate Trump and they hate when the
Conservatives have effective government
but where are the journalists on this
why don't they mention this why don't
they talk about it finally we're pushing
back you know it used to be that ex
presidents didn't criticize the new
president because it's it's undignified
well Barack Obama blew that out of the
water he won't stop criticizing fine I
let loose I hope that the White House
exposes every single aspect of that
horrific failed presidency beginning
with all of this BS you know the women
of the view they're very upset about
this they hate the reality of the Obama
administration they hate that the things
they really want to criticize Trump for
Barack Obama did as well because they've
begun with a conclusion they didn't
begin with the evidence and then they
reach a conclusion they've begun with
the conclusion that I hate Trump I hate
to hit Trump as Hitler Trump is the
worst and they work backwards so
anything the Trump does is really really
bad and terrible and then they realized
Donald Trump is doing a lot of things
that pass presidents and
polluting Barack Obama did and they get
so frustrated by it and it's just
delicious you're there Trump is in
office and he's joined this but that's
not to say using tear gas I think it's
immoral when you're using tear gas
against children but ProPublica just
found that the Trump administration has
secretly continued to separate kids from
their families the Obama administration
they never did that but I'm just you
know the ACLU says that kind of
separation is unprecedented so this
whole but Obama did it but Obama did I
don't care what Obama did I don't care
what Trump is doing right here right now
so she's trying to make two points she's
trying to say Obama didn't really do it
especially with child separation which I
said Obama didn't really do it but the
child separation policy isn't a Trump
policy that's a policy that dates back
to 1997 to the Flores consent agreement
it dates back to a time and by the way
the reason they separate the parents and
the children is because the alternative
is throwing children in jail we imagine
if we were putting the children in jail
what would the left say then you got to
separate them you got to put the kids in
a nice place yeah that's what we're
doing
guys so what and by the way it's not we
who decided it that's been the rule
that's been the law since the Clinton
administration now now if Barack Obama
wasn't enforcing the law I'm not
surprised at all he didn't enforce the
law quite a lot but you can't have it
both ways it would be it would be
throwing a hullabaloo if it were the
opposite as well and what you're
admitting is that Barack Obama didn't
didn't enforce the law but more
importantly than that what she's saying
is I don't care if Obama did it I only
care if Trump did it right that's right
that's what we've been saying all along
now you're admitting it it that that's
that's all it is
sometimes even conservatives will say
well it's what about ISM when you what
about re when when Trump does something
bad and then you say well Obama did it
too
that's not what a battery what in many
ways what a battery is what a battery to
bring up what about ISM is is a what
about ISM but what we're pointing out
here is that this is the law and that
this is a law for a good reason
and that this has been standard policy
it's not what about you only want to
talk about this one particular thing
just like the view lady I only well I
don't want to talk about Obama yet well
tough noogies you have to talk about
Obama that's the way it is so we've got
a lot more to get to we've gotta get to
the mailbag but first if you're on Daily
wire calm thank you very much
you keep the lights in my hotel room on
if you are not go there right now it's
ten bucks a month $100 for an annual
membership you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan show you get the Ben Shapiro show
you test questions in the mailbag which
is coming up you get to ask questions in
the conversation and do you know the
conversations coming up and I tell you
that Monday December 3rd oh I'm sorry
the conversations not get so it's the
backstage that's coming up you got to
ask questions there too though it's very
confusing there are so many places where
you can ask questions where do I get to
ask questions I don't know no one no one
answers my questions I just yell down
the hallway Ben tells me to stop making
a racket Monday December 3rd don't miss
our next episode of daily wire backstage
the holiday edition god-king jeremy
boring ben shapiro Andrew Klavan Alicia
Krauss and I will be talking politics
culture and why frozen leftist tears
make the most beautiful snowflakes so be
sure to tune in I'll be bringing the
mistletoe as always only daily wire
subscribers get to ask the questions
make sure to subscribe today do it right
now go to daily wire comm we'll be right
back
I'm gonna get through all of these today
from Scott Michael when do you expect
the left's romanticism of having mental
illnesses will be over my wife a hard
lefty always talks about her mental
illness and I've grown to now be non
sympathetic I want her to have help if
she needs it
but I don't want to give in to her
leftist reassurance what can I do this
is a very important question this is a
question that I have seen personally we
all know people who have mental problems
and psychiatric problems and some of
them get help and some of them don't and
some of them are on medication and some
of them are in therapy some of those
people keep the problems to themselves
and to their friends and family and kind
of close some people broadcast it they
want to talk about mental illness all
the time and the the very sad fact I
won't go into details but friends of
mine in particular who have broadcast
the mental illness and it's good to talk
about the mental illness have had the
worst outcomes from it this is again I'm
just talking in anecdotes but it really
punches me right in the gut when I see
this because I am I'm really not
convinced that talking about mental
illness is helping anybody whatsoever I
think you're exactly right I think it is
romanticizing it I think it is
glorifying it you see this so when when
somebody commits suicide and people talk
about the suicide the suicide is on
television you see a spike in suicides
it makes it more accessible it makes it
more comfortable it is it is the most
heinous act that you can commit it is so
contrary to nature and to natural law
and it is just awful because it's all
out there and we're talking about it as
though it's normal it's a very bad idea
and don't you know when people who have
mental illnesses say we need to talk
about mental illnesses
you might remember they have a mental
illness they're not they don't have I
don't mean that in any glib way that
they don't have a a ton of authority on
this exactly I agree entirely I hope
because what they're doing is they're
trying to do what the left has done with
with identity Paul
with intersectionality which is take
insanity or madness or mental illness or
whatever you want to call it and make
that a privileged victim group that
carries privileges mental illness
doesn't carry any privileges mental
illness is awful it is so terrible I
I've seen it in friends of mine and it's
just awful they should not pretend it
carries any privilege that it's nice
that it should be celebrated or talked
about it should be medicated it should
be fixed and we should pray for people
who have it and anybody who encourages
people to celebrate or indulge their
mental illness is is really doing great
harm to that person into society from
Jean hello mr. Noles I recently found
meaning in religion I come from an
atheist strict atheist home and I
absolutely never came in contact with
religion over the first 25 years of my
life I really get the importance of
Christianity the values it brought to
our society but I can't bring myself to
really believe in my head
Christianity is basically just a set of
really good values that help you live a
meaningful life yeah I don't know if I'm
just being hypocritical but I don't
think I could ever really believe well
you should I really think that you
should it's it's good that you get the
importance of Christianity it's good
that you see the utilitarian argument
that it's good for society that it's
good for the individual I think a lot of
people are there I was there for a long
time I was there from probably 18 or 19
through 23 so I I get you I was a kid
once that's fine what you have to ask
yourself is why is it why is it good for
society why is it good for individuals
to believe that God the divine logic of
the universe the only begotten Son of
God was incarnate in the year out right
around the Year Zero and in in Bethlehem
and became man and died for our sins and
then was resurrected and conquered death
why why does that value matter why do
the values that come from that matter if
you if it produced good values then what
was it did it really happen or did it
not really happen
is Jesus a man who walked on the earth
who was crucified died and was buried
and resurrected on the third day and
conquered death and redeemed us from our
sins or is it just a story is it false
if it's false give me the evidence that
it's false I don't see much evidence I
see a lot of evidence that it's true if
it's good for society and why isn't it
good for you what what is good about
that
the one way that you can maybe get
yourself to believe is to read
apologetics this is what I did because
what it sounds like is that you're
having you've had the intellectual
conversion but you haven't had any
spiritual movement that's fine we've all
been there read mere christianity by CS
lewis read orthodoxy by Chesterton read
and really anything by those guys read
the Hilaire Belloc read any you know the
more modern apologists then pray then go
to church drew has this thing he says
how to find God in 60 days act as though
God exists pray take care of yourself
that sort of thing see what happens
after that I have great hope that you
will find that it's not just useful but
that it's useful for a reason from
Elliott hi Michael with the Democrats
taking the house do you see a path for
us to get funding to build the wall in
the next six years assuming Trump's
re-election or has that dream passed
into the great blue yonder there is hope
which is that we need to shut down the
government and get the wall funding
right now this second that's the only
way we're gonna get it we're not going
to take the house back in 2020 probably
historically that would be very unlikely
so do it now shut down the government
get funding for the Justice Department
and for DHS get the money to build the
wall not a quarter of the wall not half
the wall build the whole wall do it now
who cares if we shut the government down
it redounds to our benefit politically
either way either we get the wall which
is good or Democrats let illegal aliens
one-third of whom have sicknesses HIV
hepatitis lice all this sort of things
pour over to the border caravans full of
criminals just pouring over the board
either way we win from will hey there
mister no elves and OLS get it I get it
and Christmas is coming anyway
the BDS movement against Israel seems to
be catching on more and more at US
universities do you foresee a time in
the near future whenever a Democrat is
elected president that an official BDS
like strategy could be implemented as
official US policy thanks big fan of
your work
oh yes certainly I do the Democrat Party
is hostile to Israel they are electing
people now to the Congress to the
leadership of the Democrat Party who are
hostile to Israel who don't like Israel
Louis Farrakhan called Jews termites
Barack Obama smiled in a photo with him
in 2005 that's that's what we're talking
about here they've so far sort of kept a
lid on the Jew hatred and the Democrat
Party but even that is starting to crack
you've got Alexandria Ocasio Cortes
calling Israel an apartheid state she's
the darling of the party and she's not
just a popular darling she's a darling
of the fundraisers of that party too she
was flying all over the country raising
money for Democrats and campaigning for
them there is certainly a chance that
the Democrats follow the the line of the
United Kingdom and various European
countries and condemn Israel and try to
try to promote some Arab state in what
is the nation of Israel we should be
very careful about that that would be a
terrible thing for an American ally for
the entire region and for justice
from Adrian dear Michael master of all
things Kofi Fay I would like to get your
take on tattoos would you are you sure
you'd my mother has always been a very
devout Catholic and has always been
against tattoos she would always quote
the part of from the Bible that says
that our bodies are our temple so we
need to keep them clean I've recently
felt the urge to get one but would like
to hear other people's opinions as well
and you have been my go to for most
things that have to do with the Catholic
faith love the show keep up the good
work
Adrienne I'll give you an answer I don't
know if this is the exactly the Catholic
answer but this is just my answer
broadly if you are a marine or a convict
get a tattoo you should have a tattoo if
you you served in the military you know
and you've or you've been convicted of a
crime you you make a good case you can
get a tattoo if you want to tattoo for
other people it's a little tough
you know looked could I wear a tattoo
could I wear a face tattoo like Mike
Tyson no I just don't I I don't have the
body for it I don't have the personality
for it it's not going to work some guys
get tattoos like little hipster whiny
guys get tattoos and it's pretty sad
if you are kind of burly dude and
whatever you were too that's fine I
guess whatever that's fine women ladies
if you have a tattoo don't get any more
if you don't have a tattoo don't get one
Adrienne is a name that could go either
way so I'm to give you both answers I
don't like them some people really like
them I don't like them I especially
don't like them on women if they're
hidden that's cool whatever that's fine
if they're really out there I just don't
like it
that's my preference tattoos have been
around since the dawn of man there is
evidence that the Visigoths had tattoos
Native Americans have had tattoos
they've been around for a long time but
I don't like them I think there's a
reason why in the West in most of
civilized society we've kind of gotten
rid of them but there were always
eccentric aristocrats who would wear
tattoos English royalty that sort of
thing just as my preference I don't like
them but you do you kid from Katherine
dear mr. Noles did you hear about the
scientists in China who is claiming to
have made the first Jean edited babies
using CRISPR and IVF most scientists
still see that this is a big problem
ethically and morally but not all all
those support for this type of science
is still uncommon do you think more
people will begin to defend such
practices what would be the long-term
consequences yes so the story that's
come out of China is this scientist has
created a gene edited baby who's gone in
changed the genes of a baby to be a
certain way and that and now that this
baby exists in the world this many more
people will be will defend these
practices this is the logical
consequence of a society that condones
abortion and in vitro fertilization
because what those techniques do one
abortion kills babies in vitro
fertilization switches the natural order
and makes babies for the parents as
though as look as though rather than
parents raising babies its babies are
being created for the the red
vacation of the parents and in in vitro
fertilization you can kind of pick what
you want I'm not saying everyone who
does this does that but very frequently
you fertilize a number of eggs you've
got the little little individual humans
that will be implanted and you can pick
which ones you want to keep and which
ones you don't want to keep and if you
don't if you choose to keep all of them
you end up like Octomom and you have
eight eight kids and you that's a rarity
this is the logical consequence of that
which is that we can make whatever sort
of babies we want designer babies super
babies this is going to continue it's it
it's a horrific ly terrifying bioethical
problem but the cats out of the bag and
we really let the cat out of the bag
decades ago all right on that happy note
that's our show enjoy the weekend I will
finally be back in la-la land
starting next week next Monday and so
it's been a lot of fun being on the road
with these speeches be sure to tune in
because we're going to be doing
backstage then as well in the meantime
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Noel's show try not to get indicted by
Bob Muller over the weekend
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018